thank you for welcoming me anyway I'm
glad to be here I thought I'd start by
talking a little bit about girls Inc and
talking to you a little bit about the
entrepreneurial side of girls Inc and
then a little bit about my past as well
and how innovation and entrepreneurship
have been part of that path so Girls Inc
is a national organization it's actually
in the US and Canada there are 88
affiliates and as Tom mentioned we
inspire girls to be strong smart and
bold and we really focus on navigating
the barriers that they face so economic
barriers gender barriers racial barriers
so that they can realize their full
potential and thrive become healthy
educated independent adults who wouldn't
want that right girl's leg actually
started in 1864 anybody know what was
happening in 1864 we're in the middle of
a civil war and it was also the
Industrial Revolution so young women
were coming from the farms the farmlands
rural areas the country into the city
and there was a need for these young
women to have a place to socialize at
the time the only places for them to
socialize were saloons and bars which
were not places for proper respectable
women so girls clubs started that's what
they were called in girls clubs started
and they became a place for proper young
women to socialize until such time as
they married and then would socialize as
part of their household on their family
obviously there's been a great deal of
innovation that's happened from 1864 to
now we no longer serve young women who
are 18 to 24 now we're focusing on girls
who are school age so kindergarten
through twelfth grade and girls Inc of
Alameda County began sixty years ago so
even just between 60 years ago and now
there's been a great deal of innovation
when we started sixty years ago it was
1958 there was still an expectation that
women were going to be that girls were
being socialized mostly for being
homemakers and at that time there were a
few careers that were available teacher
secretary nurse and homemaker those were
the expectations and girls were being
socialized mainly for that there has
been a great deal that's happened since
then we have a witness or
evolution we had women in the workplace
and so now when we think about what it
means to help a girl develop her whole
self her full self we're really looking
at the education aspects educational
aspects we're looking at health and also
leadership development what does it mean
to become a leader what does it mean to
practice to be able to practice and
embody those leadership principles and
so we have mostly focused on
under-resourced communities in the in
the latter years at girls in Kiev
Alameda County and now we're looking at
what that looks like for for girls so
you can ask what is it what are you what
are you talking about you know what does
that look like well we have girls who
are we're working with and they live in
areas where in their school one out of
five children from a low-income
household reads at grade level by the
end of third grade one out of five that
means that 80% of children in that
school are not prepared to go on and
have a have the foundation for their
academic success set up because third
grade is there when you stop learning to
read and you begin to read to learn so
if I asked you to read a science problem
and do your science homework and you're
having trouble reading and comprehending
how well do you think you're gonna do on
that science problem you take it guess
probably not so well so one of the
things that we started looking at is how
do we make sure that the girls we want
to focus on we want of course them to
have this academic foundation we've got
to start with literacy this is something
they're not getting so how do we make
sure that they get that foundation and
that's the way that a lot of our
programs have started really looking at
what's not happening and how do we
innovate around that and create a space
where that can happen so first I'm going
to back up a little bit too because
there's a premise about the gender
responsive we talked about there's a
couple things that we talked about we
talked about girls links so there's the
gender responsive environment and gender
responsive really means there's you know
there are things that we're used to and
that's probably gender neutral when you
come into this classroom we don't ask
whether you're male female we don't we
don't ask that question you just you
come into the classroom you sit you
learn
but there's a premise in terms of how
society interacts with each of us and
the messages that were told if you're
told you can't do that because you're a
girl you can't do that because you're a
boy you're actually not gonna be good at
that because you're a boy you're not
gonna be good at that because you're a
girl
so research shows that there are lots of
these messages that girls are receiving
every single day about what they should
do what they shouldn't do what they can
do what they can't do and let me tell
you the way that shows up so we worked
with a young girl named Donna and Donna
showed up to one of our programs and we
were doing some some math and we make it
fun hands-on interactive environment and
Donna says oh you know oh I thought we
all hate math everybody hates math right
we're supposed to hate math everybody
hates math and we looked at we said no
we don't we don't hate math and she goes
oh okay this is new to her this was not
something that she'd heard before and so
as Donna said okay
I don't hate math maybe I should look
into whether actually enjoy it
and she found out that not only did she
enjoy math she was actually good at it
so you think about how that shifts your
mind frame from being the Oh everybody's
supposed to hate math because that's
what we do - hmm I'm actually good at
math she actually had the space to find
what she might be good at and so she
started taking more math than she
started exploring and then looking at
what courses were available at her
school and then math led her to science
so then she gets this interest in
science and she signs up for computer
science AP which was offered at her high
school powerful I mean we're in the Bay
Area Silicon Valley she signs it for a
computer science AP would you like to
guess what her teacher told her teacher
said you know you're one of a few
juniors in this class it's mostly
seniors and you're one of two girls
signed up for the class I don't think
you're going to be comfortable in this
class you should probably drop it right
Wow
so this is what she heard what here is
it 2018 so this two years ago 2016 we're
in the middle of a really technology
revolution where we need more people who
understand computer science there's so
much that's happening there's so much
innovation and when you have a young
girl who says I'm interested in computer
science I want to sign up for this
computer science AP class she's being
told don't you're probably not going to
like it the good thing is that Donna had
been very involved with Girls Inc so she
reached into her inner core and said I
know I'm gonna face some barriers and
this is one of them
and so she looked her teacher in the eye
and she said thank you very much for
your opinion I'll see you tomorrow in
class and so she went to class the next
day and the next and the next so into a
couple of weeks and turns out Donna is
one of the students that other students
are coming to for help
who knew she's actually really good and
at the end of the semester or actually
this would probably be the end of the
year when they take the computer science
AP course there's only a few students
who pass and guess who one of them is
Donna so you think about what transpired
there there was a gate there was a
barrier and if Donna didn't have the
confidence if she didn't have the
support if she didn't think it was
possible that she could do this that
could have been a gate for her that was
closed now we have the opportunity to
think about what can Donna do with this
interest in computer science the world
is her oyster right there's so many so
much opportunity there's so many places
she can go we have to really think about
how do we make sure we stop the limiting
barriers that are happening so they're
happening in a number of different
factors so when I go back to the
gender-responsive piece I got into that
story because of the gender-responsive
piece so most environments are gender
neutral neutral we're assuming they're
gender neutral they're not really gender
neutral most environments are in our
society are built with boys and men in
mind they're the they're the basis that
were that we're going from so
when you ask when a teacher stands at
the front of the class and says quick
answer the question anyone anyone
research shows that boys are more likely
to answer there raise their hand and if
you do it quickly like that and expect
someone to raise their hand you're most
likely gonna get a boy that's raising
their hand so what do you do in order to
create a different setup that makes it
possible for girls to engage as well
with a with the information we know that
we engage we learn more when we're
actually going back and forth you might
not have the right answer
and that's not a problem but how do you
know how to kind of put yourself forward
and raise your hand how do you create
environments where that's possible
there's gender specific environments
where you say okay all the boys go over
here all the girls go over here everyone
who identifies this boy go over here
everyone who identifies as a girl go
over here
those are gender specific but if you're
teaching the same material in the same
way it doesn't necessarily result in a
shift now if you're going to be gender
responsive that means that you're
looking specifically at what the
research tells you about girls and there
are a few things that the research tells
you about girls now is this true for
everyone maybe not but it's true in our
society a majority of the time and
that's what you have to think about so
one of those things is about the raising
the hands I mentioned that so girls are
more likely to think about things to do
about them a little bit more raise their
hands a little later but if you've made
this a quick answer the question now too
late we've already moved on giving so
it's all supposed to different learning
styles so sometimes giving answers i
sorry giving questions ahead of time so
they can have a chance to ponder them
and think about them in a different
environment it also means supporting the
girls and helping them to know that it's
okay to raise your hand and not have the
right answer you don't have to wait
until the answer is perfect you can kind
of think about it or talk it out while
you're while you're raising your hand
and it might not be perfect and that's
okay then you can understand how could I
be thinking about this but there's a
couple of different things that that we
that have to come in mind when you're
thinking about how girls are responding
to that to that so one I mentioned is
the perfection wanting the answer to be
right another is the first to raise your
hand
um and and you have to have a space
that's safe to take positive risks so
that's a lot of what we do we create
safe trauma-informed gender responsive
environments where girls can feel safe
they can take positive risks they can
push themselves and the idea is not that
they will only do that in the space that
we've created but that becomes a
nurturing space where they can then
carry that with them inside to the other
spaces like Donna the story that I told
you where she told her teacher yeah no
thanks I'm gonna come back to class
right so the ideas that you have that
that core that support another story
I'll tell you is um one of our girls
ikura talked about being in first grade
and eating lunch in the bathroom stall
she was being teased so badly it was
post 9/11 and she was Muslim and so she
was being teased so much but it was just
easier just to eat lunch in the bathroom
stall you got to think about how much
you must be being teased to want to eat
in this bathroom stall and she said
before girls ink she didn't have a
positive environment where she could
actually make friends or she could feel
safe and comfortable now you asked if
you can take a girl like incra who's
really drawing inward and saying oh gosh
I don't feel safe my radar is telling me
I'm not safe all the time and whether I
can actually then go out and take
positive risks and raise my hand what's
the likelihood that you think she can do
that that she's gonna feel comfortable
enough to do that probably not very
likely right so again the idea is you
create this space where there's an
opportunity to process the things that
you're experiencing there's an
opportunity to move through them and
then you get that courage to then move
move forward so I talked about girls ink
so the the innovation has been of this
been a part of girls inks history it has
been a continually to be a part because
the world we live in it has continued to
evolve so we're always innovating can
talk to you about a couple of the the
programs that we've developed a
mentioned literacy that we developed a
literacy program knowing that we want
the girls to be
in a certain space we want them to be
healthy educated independent adults and
if they're starting out already behind
with reading that's gonna be really
difficult so we started this literacy
program and it wasn't just about
literacy literacy is important but it's
also all the socio-emotional supports as
well that I talked about making sure
that the girls are also seeing their
reading books that have girls in them
who are taking the lead not just girls
sitting by wow the boy is the hero and
the boy gets to do all the learning and
the boy gets to have all the adventures
and that's great too but we wanted to
make sure that the girls are really
seeing themselves as the heroines of the
story so we picked books that are
appropriate for that finding things that
are interesting to them that are
culturally relevant for them so they say
oh this is familiar this makes sense and
I want to know what happens I'm actually
reading it because I want to know what
happens and not because you're telling
me I have to read it and I have to spend
this next 20 minutes reading right so
there are literacy program our girls are
two and a half times as likely to read
and I gave you the stat before about one
in five students who are from low-income
households not being at grade level so
it's really important that we're helping
to move that needle and by doing that we
identified an issue what's the challenge
here and what's the opportunity what's
the place that we can play a role here
in making a difference so that's the
literacy program there are some other
examples we started a program called
build it actually with the Stanford
Research Institute I did some
collaboration on that and build it was a
STEM program that was really hands-on
and it was an opportunity for girls to
get really involved in building things
so often and I've heard about girls
saying you know we have these programs
at my school but I kind of get pushed
out of them they become all boys spaces
I'm shunned for being being interested
in this and it told I shouldn't be
interested so they have this opportunity
to do hands-on they were coding websites
and building robots and doing all types
of really engaging things you know you
learn a lot when you're when you're
using your hands and kind of building
things together so that's an innovative
program that we put together with the
support and the collaboration of the
Stanford Research Institute knowing that
girls didn't have a lot
of opportunities to build to be hands-on
with technology to be hands-on with stem
and to get engaged and you think what's
the what's the result of that well it's
really about opportunity it's really
about opportunity the world that we live
in it's so important that we're putting
our full face forward all over we're
putting our best foot forward when we
think about how we're preparing our
youth and that's exactly what we're
talking about how do you best prepare
youth and in our case specific case
girls to make sure that they're ready to
take on the world so girl think about a
mini County started sixty years ago
mention that I came on board a little
over two years ago myself my predecessor
and the predecessor before her together
we represent 40 years of leadership at
Girls Inc so it's pretty powerful you
don't often see that kind of longevity
so Pat looms who was who kinder Girls
Inc in the 1970s I would say her stent
was about 30 years and she was really
known for the growth a lot of growth a
lot of innovation creating programs that
weren't really heard of at that point in
the early 90s we had a pregnant and
parenting teens program for girls and
there was childcare on-site with the
idea that you're really supporting the
need that you see there and the
interesting thing is the other day I ran
into an alumna of that program I had no
idea but she was a mom and I met her in
a business setting and she told me that
girls Inc had a soft spot in her heart
and I said oh great well how do you how
do you know girls Inc we've been around
for so long and we've had so many staff
we've had so many volunteers so we have
about a thousand volunteers every year
we've touched so many different
organizations companies that come in and
so it's it's very and we have a lot of
alumna it's very hard to know how
someone knows of girls link do you know
do they have a friend they tell me tell
me how you know us and she said actually
I was in I was a participant of the
pregnant and parenting teens course in
the early 90s and
knew that had to be one of the first
years of that cohort and I said Wow tell
me more she's in her 40s now her
daughter and she was pregnant with his
25 college graduate and again remember
we are serving girls in under-resourced
communities so this in and of itself is
pretty powerful that her daughter that
she had when she was about 18 is a
college graduate and she tells me that
she remembers that girl's Inc was just
there for her doing a very vulnerable
point in her life and it was just really
powerful experience and that's why she
will forever have a soft spot in her
heart for girls Lincoln I thought that's
that's pretty incredible we have stories
like that she's in her 40s and so 1958
so that's a that long that long time
frame and when you have an organization
like that you're really continuing to
spread out ripples so we think of it as
not just touching the girl but you're
impacting her family you're impacting
future generations and you're impacting
the community that she touches this
particular woman works in philanthropy
and so she has an impact on lots of
organizations really thinking about her
experiences and bringing them to bear so
it's really pretty powerful you know I
mentioned about the the other pieces so
there's gender-responsive
there's something that we call
intentional and compensatory and what
that really means is thinking about what
doesn't exist already and that's really
an important part of innovation what
doesn't exist what gap is there that
needs to be filled what need is there
and as we think about some of the
programs that I've discussed they really
are intentional thinking about the
opportunities that girls don't have
their compensatory they're trying to
make up for that gap that girls don't
have and so that's a phrase that we talk
about a lot
what's intentional and compensatory what
are the things that girls are not
experiencing that they need to
experience so we had spring break in
Oakland a couple weeks ago and we took
the girls camping overnight they had to
pitch their own tents did a build there
fires and for the majority of the group
I think there were about 12 girls in
this group 11 of them had never been
camping before so you can say okay
camping is an experience you know why is
this important well it's important
because in order to encourage someone to
take positive risks they have to have
had examples of taking positive risks in
their life before you don't want to wait
until it's the big big positive risk
that's really scary and say go for it
and they've never done that before right
so a lot of our girls they're the first
generation to go to college well if
they've never taken a positive risk
before they head off to college you
don't want to wait until they're
graduated they've got their bags and
you're saying okay go off onto that
college campus you got this think about
how you might have felt going off to
college right
it's scary there's a lot of changes and
we really want the girls to be prepared
we want them to have something to dig
deep down and say okay you know what
I've pitched a tent before and I didn't
know how to do that and we figured it
out and we slept under the tent
so I can figure this out too I built a
fire I'd never built a fire before in
fact I thought they were crazy when they
told me we were gonna be building fires
but we built fires and we stayed warm we
had s'mores too so I can do this so we
want to really want to give them a lot
of experiences where they have an
opportunity to build those positive
risks and that goes into that
intentional compensatory so what aren't
what experiences aren't they getting
right now and also because they're girls
hmm some of them are still getting the
the message that oh you know what you're
too pretty to camp don't get dirty right
so it's dirty you can get dirty you'll
be okay
you won't break we good and you actually
learned something as a result the last
piece is about the scientific inquiry so
we really want to encourage curiosity
curiosity of course is a huge part of
innovation
so why encourage curiosity well in order
to be innovative you have to ask
questions in order to learn about
science and technology and engineering
you have to ask why why does it happen
this way and so part of that is that
scientific inquiry so when we when we're
working on those hands-on projects we're
asking them we're encouraging them to
kind of tinker to figure things out and
to ask questions why does it work this
way why doesn't it work this way
well I thought it would work this way
but it actually didn't so what do I need
to change next time for it to work
there's no right and wrong it's just
this didn't work like I expected it to
so what might I need to switch what do I
need to change up and that kind of keeps
you flexible and adaptable that's what
we call a growth mindset right we are
continuously learning you're not saying
it's fixed it's right or wrong and it's
wrong and so I'm done what if every
innovation that we ever had the person
started by saying well I didn't get it
on the first try so I'm done we would
never have any innovations so that
curiosity that ability to not get the
result you want to get the first time
and figure out how you need to
troubleshoot that's an important skill
and it's hard to teach it by just saying
here I'm gonna teach you this skill you
have to really teach it through
experiential opportunities so that's a
big piece of how we infuse innovation
throughout the girls like model so I
mentioned I've mentioned a couple of
different projects I think I might
transition now from girls linked
specifically to my path so how did I get
here well I didn't start out my career
saying I want to be at Girls Inc I
didn't start out my career by saying I
wanted to lead an organization in fact
if you asked me 20 something years ago
what I wanted to do I'd probably say I
don't know I mean I knew I needed I
needed and wanted a job and I didn't
want to do the same thing every day
that's pretty much the extent of what I
knew so I went into my first role and I
was trying to figure out whether it made
sense for me but in the meantime I was
asking a lot of questions I got to know
the business I talked to a lot of my
colleagues what do you do why do you do
it who's at the other end of what you do
what do they do with it once once they
get what they get from you and learning
more and more I really was a sponge in
that way and that's one of the things
that I always felt like helped me
to learn about whatever industry and
business I was in I've kind of moved
around a lot we could talk a little bit
about that so it was a few months into
this first job which didn't turn out to
be the the final career and my boss who
would this was a small company there was
probably about 12 employees there and my
boss was actually the owner of the
entire company too small to have HR and
my boss one day says offhand to me
mm-hmm you're gonna be my Monica
Lewinski right and I said who you wish
and then my mind started whirring and
clicking and I thought huh we're pretty
small there's no HR who do you go to you
don't really go to anybody so I started
looking for a new job and I had friends
who said oh you should sue and I said oh
my gosh I'm like five months out of
college I need a recommendation that's
what I need so I got out of there as
quick as I could
and I got a recommendation got into my
next role and in my next role I was
working in publishing Golden Books
Publishing and it's a I mean I've read
these books growing up the little golden
spine just seemed in the store and I was
really excited about the work that I was
doing it didn't feel like work what we
called edutainment so there's the
educational side of it there's the
entertainment side of it and I was asked
they we're kind of working on this thing
called the Internet I'm really dating
myself here but they had a website and
the website consisted of one static page
that's it you couldn't click you click
it didn't go anywhere there was just a
picture and their address that's it
and they realized they wanted a web
presence and they said okay well we
don't we don't really know what we're
doing here we need somebody to research
it well I raise my hand why why not why
not even if I don't want to do it
forever it could be interesting and fun
and I could learn something and that's
exactly what happened I did some
research I did more research and pretty
soon I was the expert on the team on
internet marketing I mean imagine that I
was you know 23 24 how could I be the
expert but I was I was the only one in
the company who knew what I knew
and so they decided to create a
department and they asked me well you're
the internal expert do you want to move
into this new department of course of
course I do right so I move into this
department and now all of a sudden they
are looking at how they're how they're
looking at their brands Rudolph the Red
Nosed Reindeer The Powerpuff Girls there
were a couple of other brands Peter
Cottontail and they wanted to create
these experiences with the brand online
because it was another way to engage the
customer so I got to build these fun
experiences I got to work with the
developers and build these fun
experiences for kids and their families
to come visit and have fun and engage
with the brands and then decide whether
they wanted to buy some products or not
so I'm literally at work testing games
that's what I'm doing I'm testing games
and I caught myself laughing at a couple
points and going I'm getting paid for
this this is this is I mean I would do
this for free I had a great time it was
a blast
and then 9/11 happened and I started to
ask a lot of questions about what I was
doing what I wanted to do I lived in New
York at the time so there was a smell of
computers and ash and burning cement and
things in the air that should not be
burned for months on the television
every night there were bad there were
funerals where bagpipes were being
played and so I started a lot to think
about my own mortality it's not
something that's natural to really think
about when you're that young 24 25 it's
not something that's natural to think
about it that young but I started
thinking a lot about my mortality and I
started thinking about what is what is
going to be said about me when I go
because we eventually all go what are
they gonna say about me and I thought
well I guess they could say that you
know I'm making a company more money or
I'm moving this profit or hmm are these
things that matter to me am I giving my
skills and my strengths to something
that actually matters and when I asked
that question I knew immediately that I
needed to shift
my focus away from the entertainment
side and more towards something that
mattered to me personally and so at the
time I started I was leading a girls
program on the weekends at the Prospect
Park YMCA and I was having a blast doing
that but that was only a weekend thing
it was a Saturday thing I was having a
great time but I switched my website
skills I transferred those and
transition those into the public sector
working with the advertising Council so
you may have heard of them the friends
don't let friends drive drunk mind is a
terrible thing to waste there's been
some more deceit but this the seatbelt
crash test dummies and I got to work on
PSAs public service advertising so there
are a lot of different campaigns
education public health public safety
homeland security see something say
something
there's parental involvement in
education high school dropout prevention
childhood asthma AIDS awareness you name
it I worked on it was pretty exciting
and at the time when I started there
they would run these PSAs on the
television of the radio so you'd hear
about this issue and then they would
tell you to either write to play blow
Colorado for a booklet who's doing that
in this day and age nobody or call an
800 number and so remember this is the
age when the web sites were just
starting to take off the internet was
just starting to take off so I was at
the forefront of transitioning all of
those PSAs into having a web presence so
now all of a sudden you know if it's a
friends don't let friends drive drunk
there's a friends don't let friends
drive drunk org where you go for more
information and you can hear you can
read all the campaign information and
and it's basically what would have been
in that brochure that nobody was going
to write to playbook Colorado about on
the internet and I got to advise
national national nonprofits and federal
agencies about how they were going to
get their message out there and it was
very different it was advertising but
very different cuz you're not selling
toothpaste it's not as easy as okay the
person bought the unit of toothpaste so
you know you're done changing awareness
and changing minds is a longer process
it's it really is this multistage
process so it was very different and
very exciting
and there were a couple of things that
happen while I was at the ad council
that further refined my thinking so
remember I told you it didn't start out
saying I know exactly what I want to do
so I'm at the Ad Council and we are
doing a strategic planning exercise with
Mackenzie Mackenzie comes in they do
some research there talking to people
and I'm part of the group where they're
getting input from but not part of the
decision-making group I didn't like that
too much and I remember some of the
decisions that were made and I wanted to
know hmm did somebody bring this up in
that room cuz I think this is a really
important point and I have no idea and I
thought to myself yeah so this doesn't
work for me I kind of want to be in the
room where the decisions are being made
and I want to make sure that this
doesn't happen again so how do I do that
well I looked at the information from
the people who were in the room and they
all had ten more years of experience
than me so I said okay great I can sit
at my desk and twiddle my thumbs and
wait for ten more years doesn't sound
like too much fun but they also a lot of
them had master's degrees so I decided
maybe I should go back for a master's
degree and I started thinking about what
type of degree I would wanted to go back
for the second thing that happened was
that again I was the the Internet expert
to the website expert on this team as
well and they had a biannual conference
and I had the opportunity to speak in
front of 200 people and I got off the
stage and I said wow that was a rush
when's the next time I get to speak and
I said oh we have another conference in
two years and I thought two years it's a
long time so I thought hmm that doesn't
work for me either so I learned a couple
of things about myself that I wouldn't
have learned before I learned that I
liked engaging with the public public
speaking I'm interacting in person you
don't get a lot of that when you're
working on your website development my
developers were in this country they
were in other countries we did a lot by
phone we did a lot by whatever the
equivalent of Skype was back then and so
we didn't we didn't actually I didn't
actually get to do a lot of in-person
interaction and I thought hmm okay
rather than so my next my next role I'll
need to think about
that looks like I wanted more engagement
and I also want to be in a
decision-making role and then I thought
about the work that I was doing on the
weekends with girls and I thought about
the meaning that I wanted from 9/11 and
it clicked for me and I wrote my
entrance essay to grad school USA about
leading a youth development organization
in my hometown that's what I wrote my
essay about in 2004 and then in 2016
that came true that's not to say again
that I started the whole path
knowingness but for some time especially
for the last 12 14 years I have known
that a leadership role was something
that I was that I was moving towards and
once I knew that then I began to
purposely act with that in mind so
really thinking about what are the
skills and experiences that I need to
have to be successful when I'm in this
leadership role well I'm gonna need to
know HR and I'm gonna need to know
management how to manage teams and I'm
gonna need to know how to manage
projects and I'm gonna need to know how
to work with a board and had a fundraise
so as I started thinking about all these
things I thought wow okay now now I've
got my directive I need to know how I'm
gonna go out and get these experiences
and I spent the next 12 years going out
and getting those experiences that would
allow me to be successful one of the
things I think about is I've never
thought of myself as an interpretive
intrapreneur I say entrepreneur because
I've never been outside kind of starting
my own thing but I definitely has I
looked back over my career I have
generally been in roles where I'm the
first one in that role was newly created
so I'm kind of a part of shaping it
scoping it thinking about what do we
need to do and how are we gonna
accomplish it and what does that look
like or I've been the person who comes
into that role and really thinks about
how do we take this to the next level
this is the platform that we're starting
from and where do we need to go now and
how are we gonna do that
so after grad school I mean I did a
stent and in consulting when I was in
grad school with Deloitte
and I got a lot of frameworks that were
really helpful for me as I could
structure my thinking and after I
graduated I launched the Chicago Office
of Education pioneers
and I'm in Chicago I'm the first staff
member in Chicago we had six months to
launch the program there I started in
December and we had one partner
we had one placement to one fellowship
placement and I needed 20 placements and
how many of our partners would allow me
to have 20 placements in six months with
no staff and only a few people in that
city knew about education pioneers and I
don't know if you know anything about
Chicago but when I arrived there and
start working on this launch a lot of
people say well who are you never heard
about education pioneers well why are
you here I don't want to hear your
success in New York I don't want to hear
your success in San Francisco that was
all I had that was my back pocket right
I can't tell you about my success in
Chicago we're not here yet so I really
had to think creatively about what's
gonna get this person this organization
behind this launch what's going to get
them to say yes and I started thinking
about what are their needs so it asked
them questions about things that I
researched well yeah it looks like your
looks like you're growing and scaling a
lot do you have the support that you
need to do that Wow the town is probably
really challenging and they would get
them saying oh yeah yeah yeah I'm trying
to figure that out and I'd say oh I have
some talent for you are you interested
in that and then they would go hmm now
it becomes a different conversation
so after launching the Chicago site and
being in in Chicago for launching that
site and growing it for two years I then
moved into a national role because
nationally education pioneers have been
about already and the whole idea was
that there was this into intervention
this targeted intervention that would
have impact for fellows going forward
but as as the time grew from the time
they did the fellowship the impact kind
of waned so there was there was a need
to re-engage them and think about what
do you do with your alumni so and I took
on this role which is really thinking
about this alumni base that we had all
over the country how do you connect them
how do you keep the information sharing
going how do you make sure they're still
engaged and as they have questions they
can lean on each other if someone's
trying to implement an HR is in Chicago
and you've got somebody else in Dallas
who's already done
and how do you connect these folks so
that they don't have to reinvent the
wheel they can ask questions what were
your challenges what are the things I
should watch out for how do I do this so
I was working on that and I had this
national role I had team I had team in
lots of different cities but I'm back in
Oakland where I'm from and one day I
happened to take a shortcut down 16th
Street
it's an odd Street to walk down if you
don't have business on it because it
kind of ends at the other end of it so
you have to split one way or the other
so you might as well just walk down the
other streets and I happen to walk down
16th Street and I passed by this
building and it's almost like it's been
dropped there it says girl think and I'm
looking like there there's no context
for this this building was not here
before so how did it get here how did it
get here you know what's going on and I
looked and I thought oh my gosh I want
to be involved I want to be involved but
I look at my schedule and I go oh I'm
really busy I'm traveling a lot for work
I have kids at home now and so what does
volunteering look like when I know from
my my experience that volunteering with
teens means that you need to be engaged
regularly so I said well it's probably
not the best time for that I'm gonna put
my put a pin in that and come back to it
and I did come back to it two years
later two or three years later when this
position that I'm in now opened up and I
thought this might be a sign so I
applied but as I think about the role of
innovation you know what it what is it
that you need to be thinking about as
you build your innovative muscle it's
really about being curious observing the
things that you see around you asking
questions things there might be a reason
that things are the way they are and
there might not be a good reason or
there might be some challenges with the
way that things are so how do you think
about kind of innovation is is not only
just creating something new where there
was nothing before but it's also about
improving and enhancing the things that
already exist making them better and all
of us can do that in our everyday lives
and you can do that from inside a
company and you can also do it when
you're creating a new company that is a
disrupter and in the industry I also
think about
that growth mindset pushing ourselves as
human beings we like to be comfortable
so how do we get comfortable with not
being comfortable with pushing the
envelope with being on our learning edge
and making sure that we're continuing to
learn and grow that's how you innovate
you don't innovate when you're sitting
comfortable so how do you make sure that
you keep pushing and that you have a
team you surround yourself with people
who keep you pushing keep you
questioning asking questions and
thinking like what if what if what if
this happened another way what if we
could get a different result why do we
keep getting with the result we're
getting what could we do differently if
you can ask those questions and he's
gonna open your mind and really engage
other people I think the other thing is
about perspectives you know you really
want to engage people who have different
perspectives than you otherwise it's
called groupthink
right so how do you know if somebody has
a different perspective they challenge
you sometimes it's a challenge and it
makes you uncomfortable those are the
people I want on my team I want people
who make me think I want people who
they're they're coming up with something
I'm going where did that come from
why did you think about that well what
how did you get there take me along with
you that's the way as I think about
innovation that that you can really
create that creating innovative teams
because after all if you're gonna
sustain innovation it's not just a an
individual kind of going in saying I've
got my new idea but it's really thinking
about how do you have a team around that
how do you have those how do you build
the culture and ultimately if you're
thinking about innovation and
entrepreneurship
it's about sustaining that it's about
the change management piece of it
interestingly enough I saw Chip Heath is
coming and I was definitely gonna say a
couple of his books are great for that
change management piece but really
thinking about how do you how do you get
people on board because even as you're
innovating there are people who are
wedded to the way that it was how do you
get them excited about this next phase
and what is it that's going to take them
along with you I mean as I think about
innovation I it's it's really the
curiosity it's that that piece that's
always driven me which is why and how
can this be better those are the
are the things that I come back to and
as you learn the business I talked a
little bit about learning the business
when you learn the business that can
generate those those questions for you
you know you can come in as an intern
asking questions and really thinking why
is it like this and and learning the
business learning who are the
stakeholders what are the stakeholders
want why do they want that and are their
stakeholders that we don't even know our
stakeholders yet they might be using the
product in a different way it might be
useful for them in this different way so
um I think I'll stop there
I mean I've talked a little bit the one
thing I didn't hit almost partnerships
and growth we talk about
entrepreneurship there's there's no way
especially when we talk about girls Inc
there's no way that we can do all of the
work ourselves so we think a little bit
about who we partner with and how we
partner with them and what does that
look like it's for us it's very critical
that there's mission alignment we don't
want to be partnering with someone who's
not aligned with our mission it's also
we have to think about the time that it
takes sometimes when you're when you're
working on a partnership it takes up
more time than you have the capacity for
but there are all these measurements
that we think about in terms of you know
does this make sense so we're gonna get
the outcome that we want is this going
to further our reach and further our
impact and how does it help us to
ultimately reach the goal that we want
to reach and how much capacity is it
going to take when you're scaling it's
it's different when you're talking about
scaling something that's technology and
it's widgets it's a product something
that you can create and you can say well
great I want 10,000 more of them it's
very different when you're talking about
people and the impact on people because
you can invest time and the same time
you invest in one person it might take
twice as much to get the same result
from another person so as you're
thinking about scaling with human
intensive engagement that's it's a
different story
but but I think it's important because
you know scale is the name of the game
people are saying scale scale how do we
scale but that that it is important to
think about how do you scale when you're
talking about human beings and saying
okay well I'm gonna sign this amount of
time and energy and intensity to you
whether or not you get the outcome well
is the goal the outcome or is the goal
you just the goal how many people you
touch so I think those are questions you
have
to ask as you're talking about scaling
human intensive projects I think I will
in there and I really appreciate the
opportunity to speak with you and I look
forward to experience as a woman I heard
the question about the Powerpuff Girls
sorry there's a question about my
favorite Powerpuff Girls and that was
like eons ago I think it was the one
with the two puffs on the side and then
there was a question about how I take
how I think about my journey as a woman
and how I take that to the girls and
help them think about their their path
and their growth the one thing I think
about is just it comes back to being
open being open to growing if I had been
very prescriptive and said I already
know exactly where I where I'm going and
what I'm doing and I don't want this
experience because it doesn't take me
along to what I want to do there would
have been opportunities that would have
been shut out of without even knowing so
if I go back to my 20 year old self
there's no way I could have known that
I'd end up here right so I allowed
myself to have a range of experiences
without knowing where those experiences
were going to lead me and now looking
back it almost seems like oh yeah it's
perfect because you did this and this
and these two came together and but I
couldn't have known that so I would say
it's it's being open to experiences and
being open to growth and letting that
leave me
a non-profit and over the last two years
what have you learned about how best to
navigate questions what are the
challenges about leading a non-profit
and what have I learned in the last two
years I would say challenges of leading
a non-profit I mean there there
shouldn't generally tend to be around
not enough resources not enough capacity
right there's there so much that you
want to do when you're trying to change
the world and you think about there's a
set amount of hours in the day there's a
set amount of staff you have there's a
set amount of resources that you're
using so I think all nonprofits tend to
have some variation of that challenge
when I think specifically about the last
two years Wow
I mean I think a lot about our girls are
really at the intersection of a lot of
the challenges that have happened in the
last two years politically not only are
they girls we also have Muslims we have
immigrants we have African Americans we
have Latinas they're low-income and so
you think about a lot of the rhetoric
that we've heard in the last two years
and our girls are really at the center
of it all and so I think the importance
of self care of realizing that there's
gonna be a lot going on in the outside
world and that you each of us needs to
manage ourselves so that we can stay the
course for our goal and not let the
other distractions stop us from our
goals at the same time it's raised the
importance of community how very
important we are is a space for our
girls knowing that they have a community
behind them cheering for them is
important and knowing that we have given
them the resources and the opportunities
to define and create their own voice so
that they can go out and advocate for
themselves is important and so that's
it's really powerful to see the girls
say you know yes this is challenging and
yes it's scary and we got this we feel
prepared
I'd like to invite the women in the
audience to raise their hand and speak
please I wonder what so creating
creating spaces for self-care that are
more inclusive than just nonprofit or
and then that's very popular in
non-profit work but how when we're
treating purpose more in like less of a
non profit how can he from that to it
and I think self-care is important oh
sorry so bringing how do you bring
self-care to to space that's not just
nonprofit but it but in a wider space
how do you think about self care and I
think self care is important regardless
of the space that you're in I think it's
important while you're in school you've
got a lot of pressures on you and I
think it's managing your social time
managing your academic life managing
your family life and I think self-care
is important regardless of the space
that you're in I think it becomes
especially important when you find that
you're pouring yourself into your work
when you're not kind of creating a gate
between like okay this is work and then
I go home I think about the work that we
do all the time I think about it at
night I think about it all the time
because it is so important to me so I
think that's where self-care becomes
more important because you have to
create a space and carve out a space
that's that's just for you to renew so
that you can give more
is there an antagonist for the girl
thinker is it more systemic problems
that you face is there an antagonist for
girls ink are there more systemic
problems station or or groups that
you're fighting against or is it more
just systemic social issues so yeah is
it is it an tightness or are there just
system aches social issues I was
assistant when I started this role there
are people who said is that still an
issue I mean girls can do anything they
want is that still an issue and then it
was interesting to see the political
environment in them and you know kind of
some of the messages that were coming
out and realizing that this is still an
issue for people who didn't think it was
an issue that girls having the right to
you know live their full lives and not
be harassed or her reined to have the
opportunity to make choices about what
careers they want to go into and to be
able to fulfill their own destiny that
that is still a challenge in many areas
and so how do we create the space not
only for the girls to know that that's
possible but also you know do the
messaging out to a wider audience saying
hey we need you to pay attention to this
we're talking about half of our
population
[Applause]
you